んはぁ泣
髪の毛自分で切ったらこんなのになっちゃった。
あぁ泣
いやー、買ってしまったよ。
お値段！！
86，000円！！　(送料込み)
すいません！さすがにこれは開封の舞ができません。
9万円はちょっとねだめだ  。
親が怒る。
うわぁ！うわぁ！
うわぁぁ　やばいやばいやばい。
やばいよ！（嬉しそう）
うわぁ、まじか！
はい　ほらぁ！
動画のサムネとタイトルみたらわかっちゃんだけどもぉー。
今回はこちら！
ドミネーターでございます。
あの、昔動画で紹介したドミネーターあります。
こちら！
ドミネーター起動しました。
これですらも二万円してるんすよ。
これもね、結構いいつくりになってるんですよ。
このドミネーターもかなりいいつくりだったが！！
こっちはね！がちもんですわ！
ガチもんではないです。
ガチモンでは無いですがガチモンに近い変形するタイプが販売されたらしいです。
常森朱ちゃんファンとしてはね。
買うしかなかった。
いや、これですらこのかっこよさよ？
これの四倍の値段ですからね。
もう、正直びびっております。
じゃあ開けます！
やべぇ、やべえ。
ガチすぎて笑えねーや。
大きさは同じくらいですね。
いや、まって、ほんとにこわいわ。
ちょっとこれそちょすとちょちょちょ　失礼します。
ちょちょちょ失礼します。
説明書がもうびっしり書いてあります。
ひとまず充電しよう！
充電しないと動かないっぽいんで。
充電ケーブル
これは？　バッテリー？
これは？あぁこれ充電するやつだ。
これバリっとしたらダメな奴だ。
バリっとしちゃったｗ
ひとまずバッテリーだけちょっと充電しますね。
ドミネーターとは
前も説明したんですけど、これを人に向けると
その人の犯罪係数がわかると
犯罪係数がアンダー20
低めだったので攻撃しないという感じで
オーバー190！！！！大犯罪者だ！
犯罪係数が高いとこれで殺すことが出来ると
そんなに高くなかったらパラライザーって言って相手を痺れさせる。めっちゃ高かったらレリミネーターって言って相手を排除します。
そうなるとガチャガチャガチャガチャぷしゅーって
変形してね　銃みたいに変形するんですけども
このおもちゃだとならないんすよ。
ところが！！
うわぁ
うわぁ　これが
これがガチモンのドミネーターでございます。
そんなにね差はない。
このこのこのこのペロロン　このペロロン取りたいんだけど
このペロロンどうやって取ればいい？
ペロロン
引っ張っていい？
あぁぁぁ！！はぁ！
うぅ！はぁ！
うぅ…へぇぇ！！
うううん
23才
いや、早くちょっと本場のドミネーター使ってみたいんすけど。
これさぁ充電どれくらい待てばいいのかな。　充電待ち
ここからいれます。
ここバッリキいっちゃわね？
ここバキス　バキス
バキスじゃねーほーだな
でもこの状態バキいっちゃうよ？
バキはやなんだけど
あ！きたきたくた！okokok
ばっちりきました。
これを
い、入れちゃうよ？
はい、はいり　うわぁぁｌ！
今光った！
あっ！
携帯型心理診断鎮圧執行システム、ドミネーター起動しました。ユーザー認証、常守朱監視官。公安局刑事課所属、使用許諾確認。適正ユーザーです。現在の執行モードはノンリーサル・パラライザー。落ち着いて照準を定め対象を無力化してください。
はい
今聞いた？
声がね　声がこっちよりきれいなんすよ。（嬉しそう）
さぁ問題ここからです。
どうすればいいですか？
本体が水平になる様にクリップの部分をしっかり握って下さい。
ＯＫ　握りました。
トリガーを半押しにしてみましょう。
おっ！
現在の執行モードはリーサル
はぁ！
エリミネーター
はあ！
慎重に照準
うわぁ！
を定め
対象を排除してください。
うわぁ、びっくりしたぁ
うっわ！やばいでしょ！
待って、怖い怖い怖い怖い
怖い
こ、か、か、が、が、ガチじゃん。
ほんとに変形しちゃったよ。
うはっはｗｗちょっとまって。（嬉しそう）
トリガー押したらなんかでんのかな？
現在の執行モードはノンリーサル・パラライザー
びっくりしたぁ！
うっわ　これすごいな！
この状態がパラライザーらしいっすね。
半クラッチ　半クラッチじゃねーや。
トリガーをちょびっと押すと
現在の執行モードは、リーサル・エリミネーター。慎重に照準を定め対象を排除してください。
かっこよ！
これで照準を定めて
押すと
現在の執行モードは、ノンリーサル
という感じでございます。
近くでちょっとエリミネータ ーモードにしてみましょう。
いきます
執行対象です。
はっはっはっは
いやーすごいっすね　ドミネーター
これ本物っすわ。
じゃあさっそく近くのやつを一人やっちまいましょうか。
てめぇだ。イニシアチブ佐竹
ん？え？嘘ですよね？
犯罪係数オーバー300
執行対象です。
お前は見た時から怪しいと思っていた
現在の執行モードは、 リーサル
はじめん…
エリミネーター
死ねぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇぇっぇぇｌ！！！
はじめんっっっっっっっっ！！！！！
♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪～